alors c'est vrai que quand on parle de
chicha on pense à un mode de
consommation plutôt sympathique parce
que souvent fument la chicha dans un
contexte un peu convivial avec des amis
on a l'impression qu'on fume quelque
chose de plutôt agréable puisque ça va
être à la pomme à la fraise sauf que
toutes les études sont formelles il
existe exactement les mêmes risques
lorsque vous consommez la chéchia que
des maladies cardiovasculaires
pulmonaires que certains cancers mais si
jamais vous fumiez du tabac classique et
puis nous donnerait juste trois chiffres
vous avez 25 fois plus de goudron dans
la chicha que dans une cigarette dix
fois plus de monoxyde de carbone dans la
chicha que dans une cigarette et 2,5
fois plus de nicotine dans une chicha
que dans la cyber est donc la chicha
pourquoi pas en consommer mais vraiment
avec modération avec dans l'esprit qu'il
ya plus de 4000 substances chimiques qui
sont pour la plupart nocifs pour notre
santé donc on consomme avec modération
c'est pas un truc plutôt cool qu'on
devrait faire très régulière avec toi je
fais souvent un jeu avec mes potes tu
fais une chicha perché
touché en fait si chacun est à palois
devront toucher ton père non mais c'est
vrai donc voilà donc la chicha ces noms
agissent à éviter la chicha booster son
immunité grâce ou sourire mais alors
c'est vrai que souvent je vois des
patients qui me demandent comment est ce
qu'on fait pour booster mon immunité
vous auriez pas des compléments des
vitamines ça c'est la question qui
revient souvent trop vite cité la
question qui revient souvent et on
savait pas quoi faire tout ce toutes les
vitamines sont contenues dans une
alimentation n'allait pas dépenser votre
argent dans des compléments alimentaires
ça sert pas à grand chose ça coûte de
l'argent et ccrp et surtout le bénéfice
est plutôt limitée en revanche qu'on
oublie c'est que la meilleure façon de
préserver son immunité c'est d'avoir un
beau sourire pourquoi lorsque vous avez
de la plaque dentaire vous allez avoir
des bactéries qui vont provoquer ce
qu'on appelle une gingivite arrêt
gingivite celle inflammation de la
gencive jusque là c'est pas très évident
à une vigilance
pour éviter les dieux une bactérie qu'on
appelle porphyromonas gingivalis un nom
un peu barbare mais cette bactérie elle
va produire une molécule qui provoque de
l'inflammation qu'on trouve dans le
cerveau de malades atteints de la
maladie de parkinson en mer de la
maladie d'alzheimer donc par le simple
fait de se brosser les dents on peut
lutter contre l'inflammation qui va être
créée dans la bouche perpétuel et donc
il suffit d'aller voir son dentiste
régulièrement pour déjà être en
meilleure santé donc c'est du quotidien
prendre soin de ses dents c'est prendre
soin de sa santé
jérôme jeu revenant volonté
longtemps
par jour au minimum si le midi on n'a
pas le temps de se brosser les dents le
fait de mâcher un chewing-gum sans sucre
l'accord mais de sécréter de la salive
alors il réalise un antibactérien
naturel qui permet peut-être d'éviter le
lundi dragon c'est moi je te dis paquet
devant les chiens non plus ça nous
permettra d'arrêter de tuer de la laine
je remets face à lille ça ça jaunisse et
les dents sait pas qui a fait ça jaffe
la cigarette bien ça c'est sûr mais le
bonheur un jeu d'enfant quoi c'est vrai
qu'on vient de paraître un peu
particulière alors c'est vrai qu'il
mieux vaut être riche et en bonne santé
que pauvre et malade honnêtement pas se
mentir est néanmoins dépassé leurs
études incroyable mais elle a débuté en
1938 des chercheurs de l'université
d'harvard ont fait cette étude durant
plus de 80 ans ils ont pris des
personnes qui sont issus de l'immersion
des regarde donc plutôt aisés qui ont
fait de longues études qu'ils ont
préparés à des personnes pauvres des
quartiers populaires de boston ils ont
suivi année après année pour savoir
quelle était la meilleure façon d'être
heureux et comment ces gens allaient
vieillir et donc régulièrement on leur
posait des questions lors des prises de
sang des examens ont regardé leurs
proches leurs enfants et à la fin on
s'est rendu compte d'une chose les
personnes qui sont les plus heureuses
sont celles qui vont être le plus
entouré le fait d'avoir du lien social
que ce soit des amis de la famille
permet de vivre plus longtemps et en
meilleure santé et lorsque vous êtes
malade même quand on a plusieurs femmes
[Rires]
toujours est il que à l'heure où on va
mesurer la popularité sur les réseaux
sociaux au nombre de followers et bien
finalement la façon d'être le plus
heureux c'est tout simplement d'être
entouré et ce qui est déterminant c'est
le nombre d'amis et de proches que vous
avez à 50 ans pour pouvoir vivre le plus
longtemps et en meilleure santé donc
enterrée entiers debout entouré bout de
personne que vous aimez c'est peut-être
la meilleure façon de vieillir
correctement donc j'arrête de leur part
les
réparer son écran de smartphone cassis
pour ne pas empoisonner ça c'est
important parce que le l'écran ça c'est
très embêtant c'est qu'on l'a tous vu
ces adolescents avec un téléphone
portable cassé et souvent en tant que
parent on va dire ah bah oui tu fais pas
attention ça t'apprendra téléphone
portable je vais les garder cas c'est ce
qu'on sait c'est que dans un écran de
téléphone portable on a une substance
qui s'appelle le cadmium le cadmium
c'est ce qu'on a dans de l'hélium le
cadmium ses adm iufm cadmium jeune homme
se cadmium il est présent dans les
écrans d'ordinateurs dans les
télévisions dès lors que l'écran du
téléphone est cassé ce cadmium va venir
passer au travers de la fissure
l'adolescent va être en contact et le
cadmium c'est un perturbateur
endocrinien ah ouais ça veut dire
quelque chose qui perturbe la puberté la
reproduction la fertilité notamment des
enfants donc il faut réparer les écrans
des téléphones portables des ados c'est
leur met une coque de protection plutôt
que de faire la morale c'est un conseil
qui payent qui coûte pas grand chose et
qui est surtout va payer sur le long
terme c'est le problème des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est vrai
appareil complet muscler son cerveau
aussi oui alors j'aimerais quand même
important parce que qu'est-ce que ce
qu'est ce que cela en fait il faut bien
comprendre qu'on va naître avec un
capital de neurones tous plus ou moins
équivalent et puis certaines personnes
vont faire perdre non mais on va en
perdre mais surtout il est possible de
créer des connexions entre les neurones
c'est ce qu'on appelle la plasticité
plus vous stimulez votre cerveau plus
vous limiter le risque de démence et de
maladie d'alzheimer et plus vous avez de
grandes performances intellectuelles
donc un truc tout simple que vous pouvez
faire si vous êtes droitier c'est vous
de servir une journée par semaine du
téléphone portable avec la main gauche
vous allez être un peu perturbé ça va
être dérangeant mais ça va stimuler
votre cerveau nouvelles compétences tout
nouveaux apprentissages du cerveau
permet de consommer des calories de
brûler justement des mauvaises toxines
et au contraire d'avoir un cerveau en
meilleure santé notre vin challenge et
votre cerveau en permanence c'est du
bricolage chez la personne âgée lui
permettre de sortir d'avoir du lien
social de jauger tour ce week-end les
étudiants tous ceux qui vont faire du
bricolage au moins de démence et moins
de maladie d'alzheimer que les autres
n'ont cédé d'exercice du quotidien pour
comprendre que le cerveau abricots
regarde pas comme de la pâte à modeler
et on peut le module et le modeler un
peu en fonctionnement
ferrari connaît les personnes âgées
doivent bricoler cela permet de ce qu'en
fait mine de rien quand vous allez
prendre une pelle et râteau vous allez
prendre la personne va s'habiller donc à
l'envers l'effort elle va sortir elle va
prendre la pelle elle va faire un effort
physique elle va réfléchir et donc ça va
stimuler le cerveau alors qu'on aura
tendance plutôt être à la maison pas
trop bouger et au comptant un peu en
quelque sorte s'encrasser fouet est
franchement président évaluer son niveau
de forme en 60 secondes chrono comment
on peut faire ça pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
avatar nice et on ressente seconds ont
peu évolué
alors ça c'est ça me sens mesurant votre
fréquence cardiaque on sait le coeur des
sportifs de haut niveau va être très
long parce que finalement ils ont à
coeur tellement musclée à qui a pas
besoin de pomper très fort et très
rapidement pour avoir du sens au niveau
du cerveau donc plus votre coeur va
lentement plus une en bonne santé et l
inverse on sait on a observé que plus le
coeur va battre rapidement au delà de 80
ou 100 par minute plus vous êtes à
risque de maladies cardiovasculaires
donc un show une chose toute simple
qu'on peut faire c'est de prendre son
pouls au niveau du poignet vous avez vos
deux doigts vous mettez tel quel vous
mesurez le nombre de bâtiments que vous
sentez sous votre doigt sur trente
secondes vous allez avoir un chiffre que
vous multipliez par deux et ça vous fait
votre fréquence cardiaque si vous êtes à
moins de 80 c'est plutôt pas mal au
dessus de 80 c'est peut-être votre coeur
est un peu stressé que ça nécessite pas
de charbon plus plein examen mais
d'aller voir votre médecin généraliste
il fera un bilan on verra ensemble si
vous faire quelques matches et 72 sont
pas fous par 60 est là et bien là
l'essentiel de ses traits au réveil au
réveil mais non mais non pas bien sûr
combat quand je fais un tour espagnol
exactement si vous êtes si vous êtes ce
trio liés s'ils ne le faisaient pas tu
vas pas que tu vas pas le faire quand tu
fais du sport aime bien sûr devrait
confier au réveil canton mais calme pour
cent pour le connaître sipa de minuit
docteur enfin mieux jamais je n'y allais
pas de service n'est pas faire quand
c'était faire quand j'étais dedans comme
c'est fort quelle mauvaise émission
encore
la barbe maintenant mais c'est s'impose
pas possible sans rigoler je leur
parlerai après je vais lui parler après
l'escale j'ai dû parler à présent qu est
ce qui se passe je l'expliqué les
battements de coeur comment ça se passe
c'est quoi cette histoire de boire son
urine
baeza je vous le dis oui il vaut mieux
boire son urine car oui ce qui
tue mais deux pilotes
dangereux justement ce qu'on appelle
l'urinothérapie madonna la dorsale bois
son urine helix a des vertus on va en a
vu sa gueule
[Applaudissements]
l'impact ne sont qu'à 4 millions
d'adeptes en allemagne 1 million au
japon de personnes qui vont boire leur
urine pour en meute être en bonne santé
en sarre strictement à rien et les
urines vous avez des déchets
tous les minéraux que vous allez éliminé
ça vous n'avez pas besoin vous n'allez
pas les réabsorber l'extrait tout ça
pour vous voir rappeler qu'on a un
organe extraordinaire qui s'appelle le
rhin souvent vous voulez des cures pour
ou détoxifier or le reims un organe
extraordinaire qui va vous détoxifier
mais qui va souffrir en silence
l'insuffisance rénale c'est une maladie
silencieuse qui coûte très cher la
société qui entraîne de nombreuses
autres pathologies mais qu'on peut
dépister avec une prise de sang tout
simple donc ce qu'on recommande c'est à
partir de 40 ans vous allez voir votre
médecin généraliste ou fait d'oser ce
qu'on appelle la créatinine c'est ce qui
va c'est un produit de dégradation des
muscles 6,7 créatinine est élevée c'est
peut-être vous avez de l'insouciance
rénale et vous devez être suivi donc
quand je vous parle du jury de thérapie
c'est pour vous sensibiliser aux
pouvoirs extraordinaires durant d'accord
oui dans ma famille y avait une
tradition justement où on est chargé
mais quand on buvait un demi verre
d'uriné ça renforçait le x nom savant
des plus cons
alors oui donc oui c'est faux ça
je suis contente pas faire partie de
cette famille
le conseil fait le plein des conseils
aura pas tout faire bien entendu
mesdames porter la culotte oui alors
c'est un truc que alors on sait qu'une
femme à avoir ses règles environ à l'âge
de 10 ans jusqu'à 50 ans a fait six
années de sa vie avec des règles on va
lui donner des serviettes hygiéniques
des produits qui sont constitués
majoritairement de plastique à ce que
vous regardez la composition d'une
serviette hygiénique vous allez voir
polyester des trucs finissant esther
c'est du plastique que vous mettez dans
votre culotte au contact des muqueuses
et un rapport de la nes en 2019 l'
agence de sécurité sanitaire disait que
dans les salles et hygiénique il y avait
dedans des phtalates des furanes et du
glyphosate regarder mais rassurez-vous
les perturbateurs endocriniens mais dans
ce rapport on vous dit rassurez vous
elles sont présentes en toutes petites
quantités demain je vous donne un verre
d'eau avec un peu de glyphosate même si
je vous dis que ça va aller vous ne
devrez pas donc ce qu'on recommanderait
ce qui serait peut-être préférable c'est
qu'à la fois que les industriels
changent leurs comportements qu'on mette
des serviettes hygiéniques de meilleure
qualité entre un lâche et son entrain
mais ça coûte de l'argent ne peut pas se
permettre d'acheter des serviettes
hygiéniques dans ces cas là on peut
proposer c'est pas très sympa des
culottes menstruel beaucoup moins
dangereuse pour éviter que le sang soit
au contact des muqueuses plein de
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est fou
très franchement on avait cessé ses
formes ouais je sais crémant abehsera
nous
rentrait de soirée avant une heure du
matin ou après 6 heures c'est quoi cette
histoire oui alors en fait on a tous une
courbe de température cette température
elle varie au gré de la journée lorsque
la température est élevée c'est le
moment où on va être actif le matin elle
va monter c'est le moment d'être
productifs les enfants sont en capacité
d'apprendre des choses vers 12h 13h 14h
on a tous eu coup de barre où la
température chute c'est le moment où les
enfants ne devraient se proposait
voudrais pas faire des maths du français
tout alla et puis le soir après une
heure du matin la température est la
plus basse c'est là où la vigilance est
la plus faible et c'est là où les
accidents de la route vont survenir
entre 2h et 3h du matin si vous rentrez
à ce moment là votre vigilance est au
plus bas et donc vous risquer un
accident donc il faut rentrer soit avant
une heure du matin quand vous êtes
encore un peu en forme soit après cinq
ou six heures là où la température va
commencer à remonter votre vigilance
remonte et là on risque un peu moins
d'accidents c'est pour comprendre qu'on
a des rythmes biologiques et qu'il
détermine notre santé un croire alors
est un autre qui est important c est ça
ouvrier vraiment écouter ce que les
pouvoirs du don sur votre servante à
donner
c'est donner donner vous le rendra
combat c'est à ce moment là resteront en
fait on a proposé à des gens une
expérience assez incroyable on leur
propose de faire deux choses soit dans
l'ordre une somme d'argent et tous les
jours ils ont la possibilité soit
d'utiliser cet argent pour eux-mêmes
soit de la donner à des personnes et à
la fin on y va on évalue leur niveau de
satisfaction la seule chose qui ne
s'épuise pas c'est lorsque vous donnez
aux autres au bout d'un moment et à ce
qu'on appelle l'adaptation hédonique on
sait que lorsqu'on donne à des enfants
régulièrement des cadeaux une fois deux
fois trois fois au bout d'un moment qui
sont gavés en revanche le seul plaisir
qui ne s'épuise pas c'est le don le fait
de donner nous rend tout simplement plus
heureux inséré
cyril du bien sûr acquis siens c'est
quoi ces histoires de carotte pour les
yeux oui les carottes en fait elles sont
riches en bêta-carotène on sait que le
bêta carotène devons protéger l'oeil en
particulier delà des mails à la
dégénérescence maculaire liée à l'âge et
on s'est rendu compte que les personnes
qui ont consommé un peu plus de carotte
que les autres et bien vont avoir moins
de démêler d'aidé mais la moins sévère
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a
un pouvoir extraordinaire c'est celui de
notre alimentation il est possible
d'être malade mais si en bonne santé au
travers des fruits et légumes on vous le
dit régulièrement manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour faites du sport ça
saoule mais pourtant c'est vrai mais
lorsqu'on vous explique clairement que
ces carottes vont protéger vos yeux
peut-être que cet argument fera que
wazir bloquer la prochaine fois je vais
faire un petit effort bien sûr elle est
franchement c'est passionnant et c'est
passionnant oui il ya d'autres aliments
comme ça qui sont des aliments
protecteurs entre lille et auxerre je
crois que la presse
doit avoir des jambes musclées faut
manger des légumes verts n'ont souvent
on associe ses vacances mais c'est super
parce qu'en fait on s'est rendu compte
que dans les légumes notamment dans les
régulières mais aussi dans la betterave
vous avez des nitrates haricots verts
rappellent qu'ils ont un pouvoir
extraordinaire à ses deux lancers la
capacité musculaire pour n'observer le
régime de deux types de personnes départ
des consommateurs de légumes donc on va
dire les végétariens ont peut-être moins
de force et des gens qui mangeaient
beaucoup de viande et bien finalement
les consommateurs de légumes ont 10 % de
puissance musculaire que les autres
niveau des jambes avec eux ceux qui ont
consommé de la viande blanche et
d'haricots verts
du quotidien et qu'on peut tuer en fait
on s'en doutait on sert bien manger des
fruits et des légumes mais là c'est un
truc et c'est la science qui le dit
c'est incroyable franchement est là je
suis est sa chaussette paraît donc il
faut que je mange plus de haricots verts
pour le tournoi en quoi les petits pois
c'est très bien les haricots verts les
brocolis il abritera les betteraves et
d'ailleurs sur les taux tour de france à
un moment lorsqu'on fait des contrôles
antidopage on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient tous les urines rouge en fait
ils ont tous consommé de la bi tra mais
on sait que c'est un dopant qui permet
justement de créer plus de muscle donc
au travers notre alimentation
et c'est de demander combien
je mangeais de la betterave tous les
colis choqué je veux tous les soirs et
évidemment j'ai de la betterave tous les
soirs franchement je suis une grosse
semaine faut manger de la bête rare ici
vous êtes dans une grosse semaine font
marque honda l'on va parler de vous la
155 de la lumière contre la dépression
c'est vrai c'est moi l'histoire lui
donnant on le voit en la gamine
inquiétudes ayant fermé c'est vrai qu on
en rigole mais la dépression
et il ya de plus en plus de dépression
avec tout ce qui s'est passé avec tous
les événements qu'on a connu et c'est
vrai qu'il ya un petit truc contre la
dépression exactement alors on a tous
connu cette dépression ap saisonnière
quand il fait froid quand il pleut
lorsque il fait nuit à 17 heures on a ce
petit coup de mou et ça peut être
responsable d'une dépression saisonnière
on sait que la luminothérapie c'est à
dire des exposés à une petite lumière
qui va être délivrée une intensité
lumineuse qu'on évalue à 10 milles luxe
c'est l'unité de mesure 30 minutes tous
les jours le matin permet de traiter
cette dépression et on va même aller
plus loin on s'est rendu compte que lors
d'un épisode de dépression si on associe
cette luminothérapie avec un traitement
eh bien on fait mieux que si on donne
uniquement le traitement ça veut dire
qu'avec la simple lumière on peut déjà
aller mieux ça paraît tout bête et
souvent on veut parler de prendre des
médicaments pour aller mieux je
terminerai avec cette chose qui est
absolument incroyable lorsque vous à un
épisode de dépression on a là des prix y
est mais n'est pas très bien le fait de
pratiquer 30 minutes d'activité physique
trois fois par semaine chez unibet mais
non mais c'est juste ça 3 30 minutes
trois fois par semaine ça fait aussi
bien des psychothérapies regardant
médicaments ces trois mois les résultats
sont exactement les mêmes sur les
symptômes de dépression et sur la
récidive je vous reviens en faisant du
sport en fait ça devrait être le premier
des traitements qu'on a
même rembourser ça coûterait moins cher
à la collectivité même reid a toujours
que je suis mythique une bonne
chose qu'on peut tout ce monstrueux quoi
c'est vrai si on fait pas de libido
thérapie par exemple à ce que le fait de
d'avoir les rideaux qu'on laisse ouvert
et on se réveille avec la vraie lumière
du temps alors il faut s'exposer le
matin à la lumière c'est un bon
synchronise à tort de l'horloge
biologique ça nous permet d'être actif
et al'inverse le soir il faut commencer
à baisser la luminosité est évidemment
celle des écrans géants mais à la maison
on peut mettre des bougies par exemple
puisque on oublie que les led et les
lumières qu'on a à la maison elles vont
perturber notre sommeil de la même façon
que de téléphones portables l'unc le
soir on tamisent la lumière on met petit
hameau sphère cosy et du coup on va
mieux son dormir et du coup on aura
moins problèmes de sommeil soir dans
petites lumières tamisées et en squash
cosider métrage
[Rires]
un call back
ah non
et
si vous nous rejoignez zéro contrainte
surtout ne changez rien dit me mohamed
48 astuces pour rester en bonne santé
écouter tout ce qui nous dit à 20h28 un
dhimmi mohamed vous savez j'ai deux
passions dans la vie bien entendu vous
le savez le sport et la lecture et c'est
vrai que la lecture c'est très très
important de lire un voilà moi je dis à
peu près quatre livres pas que vous
lisez en ce moment c'est rilsan
indiscrétions bien sûr nous avons eu la
très
bonne hauteur le monde à des hauteurs du
golan ou oui c'est bataille et fontaine
oui alors la lecture là un pouvoir
extraordinaire c'est celle de pouvoir
ressentir les émotions des autres on
s'est rendu compte que les personnes qui
vont lire de façon régulière des romans
et bien ont cette capacité à savoir ce
que l'autre pense souvent lorsqu'on
regarde quelqu'un lui dit mais tu as
l'air pensif qu'est ce qui t'arrive et
là tout d'un coup tu as oui
effectivement j'étais dans mes pensées
et bien la lecture va stimuler
l'empathie vous allez réussir à sentir
lorsque les autres ressentent tout
simplement en lisant et puis dernière
chose à s'est rendu compte alors on est
tout le temps sur les tablettes
numériques que les apprentissages son
meilleur lorsque vous avez un vrai livre
la lecture le fait d'aller acheter un
livre de le prendre à la maison de
l'ouvrir de le sentir de lire est
nettement plus bénéfique pour les
apprentissages que d'avoir un écran
monotone qui va nous perturber donc
c'est l'histoire de se dire on va
revenir aux fondamentaux on va lire un
livre ça la portée de tout le monde mais
ça veut dire que un enfant qui aurait la
prendre le même apprentissage sur une
tablette ou sur un livre il apprendre à
mieux la même leçon sur sur le livre que
les apprentissages sont meilleurs au
travers d'un vrai livre draps c'est pour
ça que nous moi personnellement je reste
un peu old school j'ai du mal à lire
avec une tablette mais finalement c'est
un peu une intuition qu'on a mais qui
finalement la bonne équipe prouvé par la
science les apprentissages sont ailleurs
à bien dans les vieux bouquins aller me
balader pour quand acheter des vieux
livres et lire après comme ça au coin du
feu
j'aurai ma vie sa belle histoire mais si
on lit jamais je n'ai jamais la vraie
question est là
[Applaudissements]
senna
j'ai eu d'autres un prospectus un train
dans la boîte aux lettres les des promos
tout ça j'ai dit alors jamais jamais
alors évidemment pas d'un changement
myopathies crainte maintenant voilà moi
ça me peut-être mais en méchant non non
pas spécialement non mais là c'est que
ça tu n'es pas du tout alors l'idée
c'est de s'ouvrir au monde de faire des
activités diversifiées d'absence de
nouvelles langues ou stimuler le cerveau
en permanence la diminue le stress
c'est vraiment voilà encore une fois si
on n'aime pas trop lire pas de
contraintes 0 content is by
qu'est-ce que ça moi je lis un livre par
semaine ah ouais ouais c'est quoi là je
dis l'autobiographie de mac lesggy
pas possible sans rigoler mais c'est pas
possible
elle s'appelle le égalem su ce
thème le prêtre a avalé chine dans un
instant on va parler d'un truc prendre
aux soins du coeur des femmes ce sera
notre dernier
mois delà de la journée de la femme
ayant la journée de la femme c'est tous
les jours prendre soin du coeur des
femmes il va nous dire de quoi il s'agit
jimmy mohamed